[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à tous les retraités
parmi vous savent les risques que
prennent les retraités quand ils sortent
de sa retraite en fait par rapport à la
présentation précédente
j'ai l'impression de ne pas avoir pris
beaucoup de risques avec ma profession
en revanche l'objet de mon étude de mes
études sont des objets à risque
il s'agit de virus les virus tout le
monde les connaît plus ou moins par
expérience expérience souvent
malheureuses sont des micro organismes
qui provoque des maladies la rougeole la
grippe le sida et pour faire face à ces
menaces
il faut comprendre comment ça fonctionne
et c'est ce que je me propose de faire
en partie le virus est un organisme
biologique très simple est minuscule et
pour entrer dans le monde des virus je
vous propose de le faire par le critère
de la taille on commence par des objets
visibles à l'oeil nu comme un grain de
café un grain de riz 1 une larve de de
farine sécher convient de voir tout à
l'heure et ça c'est l'ordre du
centimètre ou de quelques millimètres on
passe ensuite dans le monde des cellules
ces cellules qu'on mesure en millionième
de mètre 10 à 100 millionième de mètre
vous voyez ici une cellule de la pop en
saisit elle va revenir on passe ensuite
dans le monde des bactéries les
bactéries sont des micro organismes qui
dont la taille se mesure en micromètres
en millièmes de m micro m et puis on
arrive dans le monde des virus le monde
des virus qui se mesure en milliardièmes
de mètre sans une centaine de
milliardième de mètre qu'on appelle
nanomètres
allons une étape plus loin pour arriver
dans le monde des molécules les
molécules se mesure en nanomètres
milliardièmes de mètre
et dans ce monde eh bien on trouve des
des acides nucléiques des protéines et
c'est bien parce que voilà les
constituants du virus un virus c'est un
acide nucléique un génome au centre
entouré par des protéines
voilà le virus bien sûr il n'est pas
visible à l'oeil nu mais par microscopie
électronique on peut le mettre en
évidence une couronne de protéines et un
centre avec le génome invisible on peut
le représenter
après reconstruction moléculaire et vous
avez ici la couronne de protéines et il
y en a trois différentes que que le
colorier différemment et si on coupe en
deux sets 7-6 fer reliant vide à
l'intérieur ou le génome est placé ce
génome la propriété d'être très très
petit à l'échelle de la taille des virus
ce génome si un génome d'une cellule
humaine comporte plus de 3 milliards de
lettres un génome d'un virus contient
entre 5000 et 20 mille lettres donc très
très petit pourtant ce génome contient
toute l'information nécessaire à
reproduire des virus les virus se
multiplie de la façon suivante un virus
doit impérativement entrer dans une
cellule
et quand on dit ça on dit que le virus
dépose son génome dans la cellule hélas
c'est à la cellule ensuite de prendre en
charge l'information contenue dans ce
génome pour synthétiser toutes les
les constituants viraux à des multiples
exemplaires pour que après assemblage il
y ait des particules virales qui soit
produit par milliers un virus entre des
milliers de virus sorte
voilà la multiplication virale et ceci
en l'espace de quelques heures
alors ce qu'il faut retenir de jusqu'à
maintenant de ce que j'ai dit c'est que
les virus dépendent absolument 2
cellule pour leur multiplication mais
les virus n'ont aucun moyen de de
confort mais les cellules qu'ils ont à
disposition
elles doivent faire avec les cellules
qu'ils rencontrent et donc une des
propriétés que le virus a développé
pensée virus ca suivante si on ne peut
pas adapter le milieu dans lequel on se
multiplient autant pouvoir s'adapter à
ce milieu et adaptation devient le mot
clé de la survie ou la caractéristique
clé de la survie du virus
mais comment cette adaptation est elle
mise en oeuvre cette adaptation et mise
en oeuvre de la manière suivante soit un
génome
ce génome on peut même dire qu'il a dix
mille lettres
ce génome est copié autant de fois qu'il
faut pour générer la multitude de
génomes qui vont entrer dans la
multitude de virus mais cette
multiplication ne se fait pas exactement
comme des cris mais plutôt de la façon
suivante à savoir qu'à partir de ce
génome les copies qui sont issus de la
copie du génome entrants sont tout
différent on la probabilité d'être
différent au moins d'une façon du génome
qui est la matrice pour la copie et la
probabilité que cette ce changement a
été introduit et de l'ordre du 1 sur
10000 et c'est une propriété virale
cette probabilité
donc pour un génome de dix mille lettres
avec une probabilité d'introduire une
erreur à un sur dix mille on voit que
les génomes qui sont produits par
multiplication ont toutes la probabilité
de différer l'un de l'autre
si bien que à la fin la multiplication
virale se présente plutôt de cette façon
où il y à des virus qui ressemble
étrangement au virus entrants
mais en plus des virus des virus qui
diffère dont le génome diffèrent tant
soit peu de l'un de l'autre et du virus
entre ans donc une population hétérogène
les différentes tailles de ces virus ne
ne figure pas une différence de taille
réelle des virus produits mais une
différence de deux représentations dans
la population
donc il ya une population majoritaire
qui contient le génome du virus entre en
entrant dans les conditions à
disposition et une multitude de virus
qui ont tout acquis une mutation et dans
lequel les solutions pour des
changements de conditions peuvent être
trouvées on va illustrer ses
caractéristiques par deux exemples soit
le virus hiv
vous connaissez tous le fait que le
virus hiv se multipliant dans l'autre le
l'autre sans traitement invariablement
et conduit à la mort bien sûr et fort
heureusement la recherche à trouver des
médicaments des médicaments qui ciblent
une fonction virale de telle façon que
cette en présence de ce médicament qui
représente pour le virus un changement
de conditions et bien la population
virale et dans sa grande majorité
inhibée dans sa multiplication pourtant
dans la population virale existe un
variant qui a la propriété d'échapper à
au blocage donné par le médicament est
ce variant devient la population
majoritaire et continue l'infection
quelles solutions
attey a été trouvée à ce problème la
suivante
au lieu de traiter avec un médicament on
va traiter avec trois médicaments
différents qui agissent sur trois cibles
différentes
virus est dans cette situation les la
multiplication virale non seulement de
l'espèce majoritaire la mieux adaptée à
ses conditions
mais la population hétérogène de mutants
qui aurait pu échapper à cette action
et bien tout est inhibée quelle est
l'explication
si on considère que une mutation est
introduite pendant une mutation est
introduite à une fréquence sur un sur
dix mille deux mutations dans le même
génome va être introduite à une
fréquence de un sur dix mille fois un
sur dix mille et trois mutations à un
sur mille milliards
même si le virus se multiplie des
milliards de fois là la probabilité que
cette situation arrive est tellement
faible que la le virus est inhibé et que
la personne infectée infectée peut
maintenant survivre un autre exemple
l'exemple du virus de la grippe vous
savez que virus de la grippe fait chaque
année des épidémies on est encore en
plein dans l'épidémie de cet hiver et ce
virus fait des épidémies fait des
maladies peu de morts et l'est les
personnes survivent à cette épidémie
guérissent iris parce que ils produisent
entre autres des anticorps qui viennent
neutraliser l'infection virale donc la
personne survie à des anticorps l'année
suivante le virus revient et les
conditions ont changé parce que dans la
population
il y a des gens qui ont des anticorps et
ces anticorps font une barrière à la
multiplication virale
si bien que le virus est inhibée dans sa
propagation dans la population
mais parmi la population virale il y a
ce variant ce mutant qui a acquis une
mutation qui lui permet d'échapper à la
neutralisation par les anticorps parce
que il échappe à la liaison de ces
anticorps sur le virus
et ce variant minoritaires l'année
précédente devient majoritaire et est
responsable de l'épidémie de l'année de
l'année suivante et l'année suivante
encore ce variant ayant fait des
anticorps au cours de son épidémie on va
trouver enfin un troisième variant qui
va prendre la place du virus et qui
expliquent qu'année après année les
épidémies de grippe peuvent se continuer
voilà deux exemples qui vous montre le
pouvoir d'adaptation du virus
revenons aux pensées virus revenons à
une propriété essentielle que les virus
ont dû développer pour pouvoir survivre
est quelque chose qui paraît assez
intuitif c'est que le virus n'a pas
intérêt à détruire l'autre détruire
complètement l'hôte nécessaires à sa
survie
effectivement si un virus si un virus
tue toutes les zones nécessaires à sa
survie
ce virus a toutes les chances de
disparaître avec son hôte
c'est un peu moins intuitif que le virus
n'a même pas intérêt à rendre l'autre
qu'il infecte malade parce que cette eau
de malade peut ne pas représenter un
autre qui a suffisamment d'énergie à
mettre à disposition à la de la
multiplication virale et on en arrive à
se dire que là le virus a le plus de
chance de survie s'il réussit à faire
son infection et sa propagation dans d
autres dans lesquelles il ne fait il ne
produit aucun effet délétère
est ce que c'est vrai ou c'est juste de
la théorie c'est vrai il ya les virus
chez l'homme des virus herpétiques
bouton de fièvre varicelle des virus qui
infecte 80% de la population mondiale
c'est 80 pour cent de la production
mondiale
la plupart ne savent même pas qu'ils
sont infectés
d'autant que ces virus infecte les
individus en bas âge et passe toute la
vie de l'individu avec lui dans son
organisme
un autre exemple
et le virus hiv chez les chimpanzés et 6
v est le précurseur du virus hin1 chez
l'homme il a passé deux du monde
s'imposer au monde hommes mais chez les
chimpanzés ce virus procure ne donne
aucun symptôme c'est la même chose pour
le virus ebola
le virus ebola dans son hôte naturel qui
est une espèce de chauve souris ne
provoque aucun symptôme et il a fallu
beaucoup de temps pour trouver cet autre
naturel tellement ils avaient peu
d'effet sur sur cette espèce donc en fin
de compte si la période d'adaptation à
l'autre
si les conditions ne changent pas le
même hôte pendant suffisamment longtemps
le virus va évoluer pauvre pour pour ce
multi fier se multiplier en parfaite
entendement avec son hôte
la situation change un peu lorsque cet
équilibre avec l'hôte a été établi et
que pour une raison dû au hasard
vraisemblablement ce virus change
d'espèces et par exemple passe de la
volaille à l'homme
à ce moment-là il y as incertitudes sur
la le virus qui va réussir à émerger de
ce changement drastique et alors il ya
une incertitude au sujet de ce qui va
arriver et il ya un danger potentiel est
là il ya une prise de risque il ya la
nécessité de comprendre ce qui va ce qui
va se passer pour essayer de l'anticiper
donc en résumé pensée virus c'est
comprendre le monde viral comprendre que
les populations virales sont d'une
grande hétérogénéité que cette
hétérogénéité et garante de sa faculté
d'adaptation et quelle s ous élections
permanentes pour faire surgir le mieux
adapté et dans sa population hétérogène
contient toutes les solutions pour des
changements de conditions
voilà j'en ai fini je vous remercie
en vous signalant que j'anime un blog
qui est viraux pour tout ce qui est
destiné au grand public et je vous
invite à les consulter les articles où
vous trouverez ce genre d'information et
bien d'autres merci
[Applaudissements]